en una era de escándalos guerras
culturales y fachadas perfectas muchos
tienen miedo de expresar sus opiniones
Así que reunimos a siete extraños
protegimos sus identidades y les hicimos
siete preguntas polémicas
qué revelarán estos enmascarados
[Música]
si la respuesta es afirmativa
enciendan su luz
veo porno
[Música]
si lo hago
Creo que nunca he hablado de ello con
nadie porque no es algo que saque a
relucir casualmente como Oh sí mira esa
cosa así Yo también realmente no hablo
de ello pero empecé a hablar de ello
durante la cuarentena mis amigos y yo
era como el día 5000 de la cuarentena y
decíamos ven porno entonces todas
dijimos sí somos todas chicas es como si
no volviéramos a ver la luz del día
podríamos contarnos nuestros más
profundos y oscuros secretos y vemos
porno desde que estoy en una relación no
lo veo tanto Ahora cuando yo cuando lo
veo solo con fines educativos ahora
incluiré a todas las demás siento que
todo el concepto ahora es corrupto y que
está objetivando a las mujeres si los
hombres o las mujeres van al sitio y
solo ven pornografía representan esta
idea de que las mujeres son objetos
porque es para el placer masculino ni
siquiera lo veo como un propósito
educativo porque no muestra lo que el
sexo debería significar realmente en la
secundaria era muy molesto porque cada
vez que quería llevar gafas grandes por
mi estilo me llamaban Mía Khalifa todo
el tiempo es simplemente ridículo porque
no todas las chicas de cabello castaño o
piel morena se parecen a Mía Khalifa no
tiene sentido
crees que los cuerpos velludos son
atractivos
[Música]
personalmente no presto atención al
cuerpo prestó más atención a la persona
y si me hace reír Entonces eso es
realmente todo lo que necesito cuando
era niña había un anuncio de depilación
y vi a una chica que se quitaba el pelo
del brazo Yo decía no se ve tan bonito
pensé que era muy bonito luego al crecer
me di cuenta de que quizá no es algo
atractivo para la sociedad por eso
empecé a afeitármelo Y supongo que ahora
vuelvo a lo que pensaba originalmente
para mí me parece más aseado es decir
estar Limpia para mí es no tener bellos
en los brazos sin embargo no es una cosa
social porque otra persona lo hace yo lo
hago porque es más bien algo personal en
cuanto al tema de la limpieza puedo
decir esto porque soy una persona de
color también es algo que se me impuso
como la tina como o tienes que ser
perfecta y tienes que lucir de esta
manera porque si no cómo te van a querer
los hombres el jabón sigue existiendo el
cabello no impide que el jabón te limpie
Y si te crece es algo natural además el
vello crece en lugares específicos para
mantenerlos limpios como en la vulva el
vello crece en esas partes para ayudar a
mantenerlas limpias y protegidas tener
vello no significa que no seas saciada
significa que tienes que limpiarlo
no me gusta mi aspecto
[Música]
Bueno he ido mejorando con eso
Aprendiendo a aceptar mi cuerpo y la
neutralidad corporal no positividad
neutralidad corporal desde que era niñas
siempre he sido algo obesa recientemente
me diagnosticaron el síndrome de ovario
poliquístico que hace que tenga más
testosterona en mi cuerpo que la
cantidad normal para las mujeres en el
último año más o menos he mejorado mucho
y he aprendido a aceptarme a mí misma
pero
aún me falta Yo admiraba Generalmente a
las chicas blancas incluso Ahora son las
que suelen tener éxito en tiktok Incluso
en la televisión nunca había nadie que
se pareciera a mí ahora quiero ser
blanca y pienso cómo sería si fuera
blanca
para mí tengo una marca de nacimiento en
la cara y eso solía ser una inseguridad
muy grande recuerdo que las personas se
burlaban de mí cuando era pequeña Así
que mi madre solía decirme no te sientas
así porque tú eres mucho más que una
marca de nacimiento soy hermosa como
todo el mundo y tengo que aceptar el
hecho de que no somos iguales el cuerpo
cambia y así es la vida no se puede
superar a uno mismo si vas a estar atado
a tu cuerpo y a tu cara y a todo lo que
te rodea más vale que lo ames podemos
ver estoy de acuerdo contigo
probablemente trataré de implementar eso
eso es genial
tus padres te tratan de forma diferente
debido a tu género
[Música]
mencioné antes que vengo de un hogar
hispano un hogar latino eso significa
que si eres mujer Eres automáticamente
una empleada doméstica y cocinas mi
hermano es no un hombre adulto pero
tiene 22 años yo solo tengo 17 años y
desde que era una niña me han cargado
con mucho más trabajo doméstico pero
también con carga emocional incluso mi
madre me ha dicho literalmente que si
alguna vez le pasa algo a ella entonces
tengo que ayudar a mi padrastro a cuidar
de la casa no a mi hermano de 22 años a
mí la chica de 17 cuando me lo dijo la
primera vez yo solo tenía 15 años tener
esta carga de tener que cuidar de mi
casa a una edad tan temprana fue algo
con lo que mi hermano nunca tuvo que
lidiar al menos no en la medida en que
lo hago yo siento mucho que te sientas
así puedo decir algo claro No creo que
mis padres lo hagan intencionalmente y
no creo que nadie de mi familia lo haga
intencionalmente Pero cuando dijiste que
todas las chicas limpian en tus
reuniones familiares eso me ha ocurrido
muchas veces así que siempre que estamos
limpiando Incluso si es el Día de la
madre la mujer hace los planes limpia
todo y es como una regla tácita
yo también soy hispana Definitivamente
hay machismo en la cultura pero en mi
familia somos todas chicas excepto mi
padre por eso todos crecimos
compartiendo roles nunca sentí una
diferencia entre mis primos que son
hombres
porque ellos también van a trabajar y
entonces comparten todos los roles
entonces mis padres siempre me
inculcaron que mi padre lavaba los
platos y mi madre también así que
siempre estuve equilibrado y nunca me
sentí diferente también crecí en un
hogar hispano y pude ver la Clara
diferencia en como tratan a los chicos
frente a las chicas porque cada vez que
había una acusación de violación siempre
decían sí es porque ella llevaba esto
nunca fue porque él hizo esto nunca lo
cuestionaron siempre era Bueno ella que
hace Por eso mientras crecía siempre
sentí una intensa presión para encubrir
y
callar pues lo que me había pasado con
mi caso de agresión sexual porque sentía
que me iban a culpar por ello Aunque
tuviera siete años
Lo siento mucho siento mucho el trato
que has recibido
has estado alguna vez en una relación
tóxica
[Música]
Sí definitivamente si fue mi última
relación hubo muchas cosas que hizo que
fueron
súper irrespetuosas para mí y yo no me
lo merecía Y él está en un grado por
encima de mí así que cuando se fue a la
universidad Entonces me engañó mi última
relación nos llevó a mi madre y a mí a
discutir mucho
ahora mirando hacia atrás deberías verla
escuchado Ella tenía razón yo también
tenía mucha mi padre desde el principio
decía no me gusta y yo decía que quieres
decir no Y él tenía razón
fue así y yo decía no te equivocas no lo
conoces aún
estaba en un círculo de amigos con
algunas chicas en la escuela secundaria
no sabía que estaban hablando mal de mí
a mis espaldas decían en la escuela que
yo era una zorra una prostituta Pero
supongo que como dijiste es el drama de
Los Adolescentes Por muy tóxica que
fuera la mía Me alegro de haberla tenido
porque ahora sé exactamente lo que no
debo Buscar a pesar de que fue tóxico
estoy de una manera extraña agradecida
por ello Así que no tengo que
experimentarlo cuando sea una adulta
completa porque teníamos 17 16 años sí
la igualdad de género es posible en mi
vida
[Música]
no es para nadie
están planeando derribar Row contra way
ni siquiera hemos tenido eso como por un
siglo parece que estamos retrocediendo y
quién sabe quitarlo es quitar el derecho
a la privacidad que también puede entrar
en cosas como el derecho a la privacidad
que es la base del caso para permitir
que los homosexuales se casen o incluso
los matrimonios interraciales todos esos
casos del tribunal supremo se basan en
la privacidad ahora es un momento muy
aterrador para existir como cualquier
versión de alguien que ha sido oprimido
así que no creo que sea posible en la
próxima vida
personalmente como mujer bien como mujer
latina si tengo hijos en el futuro los
trataré a todos por igual sé que eso es
difícil fuera del mundo
porque hay normas pero les enseñaré a
mis hijos que pueden ser lo que sea y
quien sea siempre que se lo propongan
quiero romper todos los estereotipos de
género Si queremos provocar el cambio
nuestras responsabilidades Solo porque
somos la generación que viene Y seremos
los próximos legisladores y jueces del
tribunal supremo creo que realmente
queremos ver Cualquier tipo de cambio es
nuestra responsabilidad nos guste o no
No puedo ser honesto sobre quién soy
[Música]
cuando estaba en la escuela secundaria
haciendo musulmana tenía miedo de
decirle a la gente que era musulmana
Porque mucha gente hacía bromas sobre el
terrorismo todo el tiempo y me
avergonzaba mucho cuando mi madre Me
recogía y mi abuela que lleva a un hijaf
estábamos sentadas en el asiento de
pasajeros y todo el mundo las miraba y
decía Aún eres musulmana No puedo creer
que hayan pensado así las cosas que
haría Para volver y ver a mi abuela de
nuevo pero a veces siento que quiero
llevar un pañuelo en la cabeza fuera
pero me da miedo que me tiren algo no sé
es un miedo que tengo conozco a muchos
que no experimentaron eso pero también
conozco algunos que sí lo hicieron No
solo padecido enfermedades mentales sino
que me han diagnosticado
ansiedad y puede que me hagan la prueba
de ser Bipolar al crecer experimente dos
asesinatos
aumentado el asalto sexual crecía en el
sur de Los Ángeles que es un barrio
violento Así que he visto un montón de
atrocidades fui agredida sexualmente por
mi propio tío y mi familia ahora mismo
están tratando de
entenderme pero estaban en negación y
mucho de mi trauma me ha afectado diría
que el Toc me ha afectado realmente
porque afecta a mis relaciones Porque
mucha gente me juzga cuando les digo que
tengo tal una de las cosas más
importantes que la gente no entiende de
mí es que me parece asqueroso que haya
tenido parejas anteriores mucha gente
cree que es porque soy misógina no sé
cuál es la palabra pero no es eso he
hablado con mi psiquiatra sobre esto y
me ha dicho que es el miedo a la
contaminación estoy luchando contra mi
enfermedad o como quieran llamarla pero
es agotador vivir con el Toc y es súper
duro
sinceramente durante toda la secundaria
he sido feliz con lo que soy conocí a mi
novia después de que me enamoré de ella
y todo me dijo que su familia es
homofóbica Pero entonces ella me dice
Oh son homofóbicos hasta el punto de que
ni siquiera puedo rodearme de gente gay
quiero mucho a mi novia y quiero estar
cerca de ella
literalmente tuve que volver a entrar en
el armario es un cambio muy grande para
mí porque salgo del armario en séptimo
grado y luego en el último año de la
escuela secundaria me empujan de nuevo
al interior Sé que debería apartarme de
esto pero no puedo porque estoy saliendo
con ella y no con su familia es triste
escuchar todo eso sobre todo porque mi
hermano es trans y todos mis hermanos
son literalmente parte de la comunidad
lgbtq sé que lo más fácil es romper con
ella pero no ha hecho nada malo ella
ella está desaprendiendo todo lo que le
han enseñado incluso he ido a su iglesia
y también hablan de los homosexuales y
es simplemente triste solo pienso en
ella pasando por esto sola ella también
tiene que escuchar eso no soy solo yo
quien recibe el golpe también es ella lo
siento mucho
Me encanta hablar de diferentes temas
sobre todo porque tenemos la misma edad
me pareció realmente genial nunca he
podido vivir algo así lo disfruté
sintiendo que podíamos hablar de
cualquier cosa y de todo sin miedo a la
repercusión creo que fue bueno escuchar
las opiniones de los demás darse cuenta
de que no somos tan diferentes como
creemos tenemos mucho en común y creo
que eso es realmente reconfortante me
alegra saber que la gente tiene las
mismas ideas que yo
[Música]